[Music]
early on when my research wasn't going
that well and I was having trouble
people be like well she's in a band but
then when my research started going well
and I started publishing they'd be like
wow and she's in a band too
[Music]
[Applause]
people think you have to be
one-dimensional to be a scientist but
actually if science gets better when you
stimulate your creativity your curiosity
all of that so to me actually doing
music helps me be a better scientist I'm
party savetti I'm a geneticist and I'm a
National Geographic emerging Explorer I
use math to dissect the genomes of
viruses to decode them and understand
how they evolve how they spread and
ultimately how to prevent infectious
disease and prevent outbreaks so yeah I
was born in Tehran Iran I came here when
I was the little girl and the middle
school me was just a little girl who
loved math so much I just loved the
logic and the puzzles and and and just
as soon as I kind of really got into it
I I never stopped math is a you know
it's a powerful tool to mine vast
amounts of data and genomics is just
thousands millions billions of letters
that you're trying to decode decipher
using math using computers so that's
what I do and that's what I love so a
virus is a microscopic thing that can
infect us and can cause a lot of harm
can make us very sick and I study all
sorts of viruses from the common flu to
Ebola Ebola is a very deadly virus and
it can have really high mortality rates
and it can spread really quickly and
kind of these worst case outbreaks it
can be 80% which is why we're really
worried about it an outbreak is an
infectious disease that's gotten out of
control
think of it like a wildfire and you
never really know where one will start
but you need to detect it
and you need to contain it before it
gets out of control that's what my work
does for infectious disease for
outbreaks during the 2014 outbreak of
Ebola in West Africa
we essentially when a patient's infected
their blood samples taken for diagnosis
we're able to take that sample
deactivate the virus within it and ship
it to the United States where we were
able to prepare them and put them on
sequencing machines and readout their
genomes so once we sequence the virus's
genome it might look something like this
this is actually a bolas genome sequence
and there's clues in here and we can use
math and computation to start to
decipher those clues learn about the
virus's history and how it's changing
all of this is arming us towards better
detection surveillance prevention really
to be able to put out that wildfire is
somebody who studies infectious diseases
we're most successful and nothing
happens right we we are trying to stop
outbreaks from ever occurring and so
we're most successful at that point when
we put up the sparks and you never hear
about it but that sort of that's an
exciting challenge so you know one of
the tools that we've created is an
outbreak simulation that spread over
Bluetooth from phone to phone for middle
schoolers to get to experience what an
outbreak might be like but before a real
life event so you know we created this
tool to be able to educate and you know
have outreach to students but really we
learned as much from them as anything
else you know their participation taught
us how about people how people respond
to outbreaks and like their ingenuity
their thought process during the
outbreak taught us so much
I love working in outbreaks because it
requires cooperation it requires people
working together collaborating and
that's how you win and it's it's sort of
the way I like to think about the world
and I'm in a band is I'm not a I'm not a
you know singer-songwriter I like being
part of a collective it's where the best
things come together
[Music]
you
[Music]
you